this is just a quick video to announce  our next computer science challenge and  i think this will be a fun one it's to  create a puzzle game on our scratch pad  and i talk about it in slightly more  depth right here with a couple of images  of what i what we're talking about by a  puzzle game but it's pretty open-ended  something that's a puzzle and a game and  it keeps escalating it and it's fun and  it's addictive and people can't stop  playing it and they might even improve  their brain along the way  and right here is just a screenshot of  the challenge which is empty and so if  you want to enter into it you just will  want to branch off of this save as a  spin-off and then everyone will vote on  how awesome your game is and there's a  link on this video and also in the  description here where you can link  straight to this scratch pad have fun